hola qué tal en este último día de la
convención demócrata se espera el
discurso final de aceptación del
candidato yo bayrén en donde va a hablar
de su plataforma si llega a la casa
blanca en 2021 se espera que bailen
hable del plan de recuperación que tiene
tras la crisis económica por la pandemia
también sus planes para inmigración al
igual que educación acceso a salud
reforma migratoria para más de 20
millones de inmigrantes de origen latino
que viven en los eeuu
también se esperan testimonios de
decenas de ciudadanos estadounidenses
que estarán contando cómo les ha
afectado la pandemia y de esta manera
finalizarán cuatro días de convención
demócrata lo próximo será la convención
republicana que se dará la siguiente
semana